it's like it's like men when they used
to pay off the mortgage when women then
divorced they were entitled to laugh
only because they couldn't earn and they
wouldn't exactly I held it down for you
to build that fortune yeah you know the
thing is right it's titled to his money
like that's so much like I'm just
thinking from the man's point of view
like if I'm building this business right
and I and I have a like I have a
boyfriend or a husband right why why
would he leave and get half if I built
it so why do women feel entitled because
with them here say say they've got
children he obviously had to work like
tirelessly to build Amazon right she was
probably I don't know I don't know the
situation I know their story but let's
just say she was at home she held down
the home for him to be able to to build
that I definitely it's not